die Bildungspolitik liebe Freunde ist
dabei nicht irgendein Thema unter vielen
eine Gesellschaft für unsere kann es
sich buchstäblich nicht leisten eine
einzige begabungsreserve in unserem Volk
unausgeschöpft zu lassen
Deutschland muss zu einer
Bildungsrepublik werden seit Jahrzehnten
wird sie ausgerufen die Bildungsrepublik
Deutschland und seit Jahrzehnten steckt
es in der Krise das deutsche
Bildungssystem versprechen packte Pakete
Bildungsgipfel mächtig und politisch
hochprominent besetzt nichts hat die
Krise entschärft kommen den Dienstag nun
der nächste Gipfel eigentlich der große
Aufschlag für die amtierende
Bundesbildungsministerin die in
allerdings erstaunlich kleinredet es ist
ein Arbeitsprozess in der Staaten wollen
denn wir werden nicht in zwei Tagen die
großen Herausforderungen lösen wir
brauchen digitale schulen wir brauchen
sanierte schulen wir brauchen modernen
Unterricht und vor allem wir brauchen
mehr Lehrerinnen und Lehrer und das
wollen wir doch zusammenstellen
von zusammen kann jedoch überhaupt nicht
die Rede sein von 16 Kultusministern
haben sage und schreibe 14 abgesagt so
auch der hessische er spricht stark
Watzinger nicht weniger ab als die
notwendige Professionalität da muss es
Vorabsprachen geben über die
Terminfindung sowieso aber eben auch
über die Struktur des Prozesses über die
Themen die zu behandeln sind also die
gesprächsgegenstände und gewisser Weise
was erwartet man sich davon was soll da
herauskommen das sind Dinge die muss man
im Vorfeld besprechen damit dann eben
auch wirklich so ein Gespräch mit
Substanz gefühlt werden kann und an alle
dem fehlt ist es fehlt an so vielen zum
Beispiel an Lehrern und bis zum
Schuljahr 2013 31 wird die schon jetzt
riesige Lücke weiter aufreißen
prognostiziert das Institut der
deutschen Wirtschaft auch bei die Zeit
der Schüler rasant Weg wächst vor allem
in Berlin und in Nordrhein-Westfalen
dort im Bergisch Gladbach leitet
Angelika Wollny eine Gesamtschule und
verwaltet jeden Tag aufs Neue den
wir haben Unterrichtsausfall es die
Eltern beschweren sich zurecht immer
wieder dass einige Fächer nicht
unterrichtet werden können weil wir eben
auch keine Vertretungskräfte mehrere
haben wenn auf dauerunterricht ausfällt
dann werden auch Schüler
ängstlich weil sie wissen es stehen
zentrale Prüfungen immer am Ende der
Jahrgänge bzw bei der 10 oder bei der 8
und ja da kommen Ängste auf
Ängste davon ist diese Schüler
Generation ohnehin schon geprägt dass
die Ampelkoalition in Berlin davon
nichts wüsste kann man nun wahrlich
nicht behaupten wir haben drei Jahre
Corona hinter uns und dort haben Kinder
und Jugendliche ich glaube zu Recht den
Eindruck gewonnen dass die offizielle
Politik sich nicht so sehr um sie
kümmert leider hat das Folgen mit sich
gebracht dreiviertel aller Kinder und
Jugendliche fühlen sich heute
gestresster als noch vor drei Jahren
eine schonungslose und auch
selbstkritische Analyse die an ihrer
Misere war nichts ändert statt
watzingers Gipfel wird für nur ein
Gipfelchen und das ist nur das jüngste
Beispiel denn der Termin am Dienstag ist
ein weiteres Kapitel einer bisher
ziemlich glücklosen Amtszeit die
energiepauschale für Studierende konnte
über zehn Monate nur angekündigt werden
bis der Ministerin die Organisation
endlich gelangen und das im
Koalitionsvertrag vor gut eineinhalb
Jahren angekündigte staatsancenprogramm
für benachteiligte Schulen verschoben
aufs übernächste schuljahr
ich glaube das dramatische ist dass die
junge Generation eigentlich die Politik
ernst nehmen will die Politik auch
eigentlich akzeptiert und respektiert
nur sie immer wieder aufs Neue den
Eindruck hat das eigentlich ihre
Generation ihre Sorgen ihre Nöte einfach
nicht ernst genommen wird und da habe
ich den Eindruck dass Politik auch gar
nicht so ganz bewusst ist was das auch
für ja Auswirkungen für die Demokratie
hat es ist also nicht nur für sie zu
hoffen dass der Bildungsgipfel den
Tiefpunkt in der Bildungskrise markiert
und es danach endlich bergauf geht
[Musik]